[Music]
we are a week away from Bluebird of
happiness the new album dropping how
excited are you I am nervous guided
meaning I'm nervous and excited at the
same time this has just been a project
that's been so close to me and I worked
really hard on it and it was kind of
like a soundcheck to my life
[Music]
you didn't hold anything back
do I often yeah yeah you know I mean
this album you know it's just where I
was in my life at the time you know
nothing in my life felt right and
everything felt like it was a question
mark that's surrounded it and you know I
just had to write and think about it
how does Vince feel about the record um
Vince thinks it's amazing he calls it my
best work yet and I mean that that's
amazing because you know who he is in
the music world and you know I'm just
excited that everybody's finally hearing
a lot of folks want to know why did you
say this will be the last album because
how did you come to that decision
there's a lot of things that is going on
in my relationship and me being close to
this music industry and whatever I can
do to eliminate all of the stress and
problems you know off of my relationship
I would rather do that protect what's
more important got it very close
together and it's really hard you know
and not only you know do we work
together he you know is my baby daddy
and you know we've been together forever
he's my best friend and you know it's a
lot of things to discuss and argue about
you know you are very much a mogul now
oh thanks but they always say something
has to give in your life what's the one
thing that gives the most that you have
to work on the most my relationship you
know me balancing being a mother cause
it's important to me to be a good wife
and a good mother this is just my job
when I go home that's my home I always
want to keep my home I think she wearing
someone somewhere safe
not just for me but for my husband for
my kid your little boy is for now he's
four and I know you've kind of said I'm
a one-and-done mommy yeah yeah see I'm
trying to think oh listen I'm so mad at
myself because I wanted the parches
family and I didn't know it and so you
know Logan you know got to be a certain
age you know I'm like where yeah I
really want more kids I would love to
have at least five Wallow where they
gonna come from yeah you know I want
them all right you ever go back to the
time TV absolutely I'm gonna leave that
right there on this table I miss you on
daytime TV way for Sunday time thank you
I do watch so maybe that could be the
next job I can't wait to get back that's
what I'm gonna say
[Music]